SPEAKER 1: --project
what we decided to do
was make a remote control car.
And in theory, what this is
supposed to be able to do
was use this accelerometer,
and you controlled it forward,
backwards, left and right.
And it'll tell the
car which way to move.
So there's a lot of
different working parts.
We're able to make
the car move forward,
backwards, left, and right.
We're able to have
it send signals,
and we're able to have it
recognize the accelerometer.
But unfortunately, in
the short time frame,
we weren't able to put
all three together.
But we can show you the
separate parts working.
SPEAKER 2: Just this
transmitter and the receiver
that's not working right now.
Everything else is working.
And then you have an
ultrasound to stop
before we get to something.
I don't know if you reset
the data, accelerometer
actually working.
If you move this around
[INTERPOSING VOICES] you--
SPEAKER 1: See it
on this screen.
SPEAKER 2: Go left,
stop, go left, go right.
I mean, the printing,
it's not working,
so you turn this around
to generate right,
turn left, forward, stop.
But this guy does
not understand this.
Somehow it didn't get them to
communicate with each other.
For example, they communicated--
for example, you telling
the car to go forward, stop
for a few seconds, and then
turn left, and then stop,
and then turn right.
SPEAKER 1: And it uses
these two radio sensors.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
For example, they communicate.
OK, and now this one.
SPEAKER 1: Actually, you
want to demo the car.
We put it somewhere
it should be able to--
we just had it going--
if we put it on the floor,
will you be able to capture it?
SPEAKER 3: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
So if you connect
it will start go.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So we just have a preset
program on the car
so you can see it in motion.
So pull it guys to
go get that now.
So as soon as I plug it
in, it should start moving.
SPEAKER 4: Nice.
SPEAKER 5: It does wheelies.
SPEAKER 1: Swing the car again.
SPEAKER 4: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: Repeat
it in a second.
Watch out.
Sorry.
SPEAKER 6: Is the ultrasonic
sensor important to get,
or is that next round?
SPEAKER 2: Yes, it is.
The only thing is
that because you
want it to, from
the accelerometer,
tell this guy to go
forward, and then we have
the ultrasound in that loop.
Like if he receives the action,
work, but for the presets, no.
The preset is just
to show you that--